let's talk a little bit about about
language because we've been doing a ton
on political correctness your dad was
not only the most unpolitical correct
person but but hated it with a passion
yeah right he really hated it and used
words in a way to show us how silly we
are being about things all the time and
I think right now we're in this very
bizarre place in our country where we're
afraid of certain words we're afraid of
offending people you talk about the line
before and pushing the limits and
yapping over the line what do you think
he would make of what's going on in this
country right now with with words
talking about this I think he would make
what he what he's always made of it I
mean in the early 90s this was going on
in colleges too I was at UCLA and
actually did a forum on political
correctness and invited my dad to come
and do that and that was coming out of
the Reagan era you know so there was a
lot of that but but if you really think
about it like political correctness
there's something about like polite
society like we're not allowed to talk
about certain things you know I think it
kind of grows out of that but you know
for him he was always bothered by the
fact that it it comes from a place of
people wanting you know a respect for
tolerance you know of of each other and
our identities right so it's sort of
well-intentioned it's very
well-intentioned
and my dad grew up in Harlem
Irish white Harlem right next to black
and Spanish Harlem yes he would have
called it black Harlem and and that
doesn't make him race it does not make
him racist and and so he very much
identified with the black experience the
outsider experience and growing up the
n-word was never ever said in our house
and my dad told me it is the one word I
mean I was allowed to say any of the
words say all seven for TVs yes but say
them in right the right places he didn't
want me getting in trouble at school and
other people's houses but
the n-word was one where that was Kelly
never ever ever so he got the whole idea
of people wanting to define themselves
and having their own identity that's a
very important thing and it's I think
it's an important part of evolution of
our species but when you do it by not
tolerating other speech and suppressing
language and speech I don't I think he
believed that that was not the route to
go about this that you know using
intolerance to increase tolerance it
just something it doesn't fit or
something you know yeah and you know
here's the thing about speech in our
country I mean if you're if anyone's
into the First Amendment it's always
that old thing that you know that thing
yeah it's always a balance between two
forces you know and so here we are where
it's about freedom versus sensitivity
both things are important really
important but you can't throw the baby
out with the bathwater right I would
argue that freedom is a little more
important than sensitivity right well
for you it is for some other people it
isn't you know but this is the great
thing about a democracy is and the way
we work this stuff out is by having free
speech and a marketplace of ideas yeah
so therefore if you're trying to control
people's speech then are you really
having a marketplace of ideas and we're
not talking about people bullying people
and insult comics and and comics who
want to hurt feelings or you know the
whole rape thing that went down I mean
there is a obviously we're not talking
about hate speech exactly but the thing
is might you know my dad did talk about
is that stand-up comedy is a monologue
it's not a conversation it's an art form
that it's a monologue yeah it was his
bully pulpit he used to say the audio
I'm here for me and the audience is here
for me
he wasn't here for them he's not there
to do with seminar and he's not even
though he was professorial he was not
there to change the world in some way
yeah he was there to get [ __ ] off of his
chest
and he did it in a certain way and so I
would love to know his new take on all
this call
College stuff and all this stuff going
down but I think it would be built on a
lot of this stuff